a group that functions well basically
can behave selfishly
with respect to other groups you haven't
pro you haven't solved the problem of
selfishness you just elevated it
to the level of the group where it can
take place with more destructive force
than
than ever
professor david sloane wilson is one of
the world's foremost kanyasenti's in
evolutionary theory
he's almost single-handedly responsible
for the resurgence of the idea of group
selection
at least he's responsible for the
popularization of it versus individual
selection
now individual selection was the
dominant paradigm of the 20th century
although he's made some amendments to
group selection and now calls it
multi-level
selection theory as usual these are
often technically dense and i expect
that there's a certain level of
familiarity with the material
or the terminology such as existential
security
victor huang's innovation oasis as it
relates to evolutionary theory and then
if for whatever reason you don't know
the material you don't know the
terminology then i expect that you'll
look it up because
you're far brighter than most podcasts
give you credit for
this conversation was filmed
approximately a year and a half ago way
before kovid
for a documentary called better left
unsaid which is all about
when does the left go too far
politically speaking because it seems
like
the right it's fairly clear when the
right goes too far this documentary is
slated for release in 2021 and if you
want to follow it the links are in the
description
generally speaking if there's a product
of mine like i helped create it and it's
more than six months old
then i'm abjectly mortified by it
because i can only see the flaws in it i
wasn't happy with the quality of it so i
took it down
but many of you have emailed me as well
as reviewing some of the comments it
seems like
plenty of you enjoyed it a significant
amount
maybe it's one of the better
conversations out there with david
sloane wilson so
hopefully you enjoy it just as much now
there's a bit of extra footage that i've
included
enjoy hello professor thank you
thank you for coming i appreciate you
inviting us into your home
no problem my pleasure all right let's
get straight to it
do you think that we're losing values in
the west
i think we're in a crisis condition so
that's a loss of something
but whether we call that loss of values
i think is
are probably too simplistic we still
have values of course
and i think that uh those values appear
to be threatened
and so uh that's why we're in in uh
in crisis mode but i think to go further
than that
we need to probe questions such as
the west what is it what does it
represent what values does it represent
are we talking about democracy are we
talking about
enlightenment values are we talking
about individuals
such concepts of freedom and so on
what can be said i think is that the
western system
is in some sense not working and it's
ceasing to become an exemplar for
others and so that is very concerning
can you explain what are some of the
values that you see that are
essential that are going away i'm just
going to move this guy this will fly
yeah right disrupting your full thought
right
um oh it's still it likes you likes you
it's group selected
let's see if we we can try to terminate
it if we need to but uh
not very that's not very group selected
over here
oh yes it is um so
that question was what again okay what
are these values so you mentioned that
we're losing
some values maybe it's democracy opposed
maybe maybe it's enlightenment values
what do you see are the values that when
we lose them we're put in a
crisis mode as you put it
well at some point i know we're going to
get to multi-level
selection which has to do with basically
how do we envision society do we
envision it expansively such as
the whole world are we nationalistic do
we view it
as our nation first or do we view it
in a more factional sense our party
first for example
or perhaps even smaller and
a lot of what we mean by the left and
the right actually
means our choice of unit
the right nowadays is restricting itself
to some tribe basically
and and the so-called left is
you might say more expansive more global
in its thinking but even globalism
itself is problematic because
i think that there's types of globalism
and the type of globalism that's
represented by capitalism
global capitalism is one which
is not working it's global but it's not
working for the benefit
of everyone so i think that's part of
the crisis is that capitalism which is
the
system that we associate with the west
is
become deeply problematic when we talk
about such things as socialism and
capitalism
um these are the modes of political
philosophy in the in the past
there's a sense in which neither one
works
and we need to come upon something
that's new that
does work and i believe that
evolutionary theory provides the key
to a form of governance which can work
at the global scale and all smaller
scales that's part of what multi-level
selection is about can you explain the
difference between multi-level selection
and
group selection is it just a rebranding
so let's talk about the difference
between multi-level selection and
and group selection and in the process
let's
define for viewers who are not
already knowledgeable about this kind of
stuff what some of the issues
are at stake and so going all the way
back to darwin darwin thought
that his theory could explain all
aspects of design
that had been attributed to a creator
everything that works has a functional
basis
he thought that had been attributed to
creator
uh he thought he could explain with his
theory of natural selection
but upon further thought he came against
a dilemma
which is if you think of anything that
we associate with morality
if i asked you to define the morally
perfect individual
you would use adjectives such as
altruistic loving giving honest
brave all of these are
things that benefit others and one
society
as a whole and often involve some cost
to the moral individual
and so when darwin contemplated the
moral individual
compared to his or her opposite the
immoral individual
well it's the immoral individual that
has the advantage
in the struggle for existence there's
something associated with all forms of
goodness
that's vulnerable to all forms of
evil and so darwin could not explain
everything associated with virtue as a
product of natural
selection unless he added something and
that something was to think about
natural selection
at a slightly larger scale so while
altruism is vulnerable to selfishness
within any given social group
it's also the case that a group of
altruists a group of virtuous
people will robustly outcompete a group
of
people who cannot cohere and so now we
do have a process of natural selection
that can favor
virtue but it's a process that takes
place at the level of
groups not at the level of competition
among individuals within groups
and so there's group selection is two
level selection
it looks at what's what happens within
groups competition among individuals
within groups
and then what happens with competitions
among groups
in some kind of multi-group population
a group inhabited by many tribes as
darwin
talked about it so you could call that
two level selection
now multi-level selection simply expands
that it goes up and down
going down we can talk about genes
within individual
so a gene can succeed at the expense of
other genes within the same
organism we call that cancer
and there's many examples of that kind
of selfish gene
or genes can can evolve by cooperating
with other genes in the organism in
which case
natural selection is taking place at the
level of organisms out competing other
organisms so it's the same dynamic that
i just described
except it's genes in organisms then we
get to organisms in groups
and do you know there's groups of groups
of groups so we could talk about
ecosystems
for example our microbiomes it turns out
that you are not just
a homogenous collection of genes you are
a planet
inhabited by many thousands of of
microbial species numbering in the
trillions
of individuals and when you're selected
when you
when you survive and reproduce better
than others in part it's due not to your
genes but to your
microbiome and the good microbiomes are
being selected
along with the good genes and they're
interacting
with uh each other in other words
what we think of as individual selection
is actually group selection when you
think about the collection of
it turns out the microbiomes is a game
changer because
before we were kind of on to that
concept of microbiomes
it seemed that we were a
relatively uniform collection of of
genes we start out as a single egg
and then those cells divide and divide
and divide but they all have the same
genes
well not really because actually
mutations are occurring with every
cell division and by the time you get to
my age do you know
you know i'm a very diverse entity
at this point even my genes the extra
mutations
have resulted in all sorts of of uh
they're called neoplasms but they're
basically cell lines that have
proliferated more than the normal
uh cell lines and that's what cancers
are based
basically so but anyhow
so for the most part except for that
then all of our all of our genes are
are identical in all of our cells so
that makes us a pretty potent
unit of selection that made individual
level selection
to be a very very strong uh
force okay well it still is i mean
nothing has changed except the
the realization that uh we're not such
homogeneous entities after all we're
some kind of ecosystem
and it's actually hard to know who's
calling the shots so
you know this is um one of the very
interesting developments that have taken
place over the last
30 years which have revolutionized uh
the study of uh
evolution that's just one that we'll be
covering during this conversation
you mentioned that the difference
between the right and the left is which
level of group should we select for
can you give me some examples something
else about the right and the left
the the standard definition of the right
and the left is
conservative progressive
keeping the old ways or doing something
new that's the standard definition
if you go back 30 years ago
then the debates would not be about
levels everyone would be an american the
question is
what should america do or what should
the world do should we
stick to the old ways or should we do
something new
and so this um this fragmentation
of social identities is something which
i think
is you might even question whether it
falls along
left right lines i think to an extent it
would but
when you look at the left for example
and identity politics and so on then
what you find is
also a fragmentation of social
identities it's along different lines
but it's still you know lgbt or
or um
all these various interest groups
that uh or you might say social
identities in which you identity
we do have to do something about this
fly don't we yeah we can't get rid of it
but don't worry we can get rid of it
actually
we can't yeah hold on to spin it can i
get up yeah sure
yeah i have actually multiple ways of
getting
demonetized instantly
you were defining what identity politics
is and then you were about to say what
the problems were can we get back to
defining what
identity politics is to people who are
unfamiliar
and you said something interesting which
is that it doesn't seem like it's the
left
and i also want you to explain what do
you mean by it doesn't fall on the left
right spectrum identity politics
okay so identity politics
is when a person has a very strong
social identity
that trumps other identities
actually we all have many identities one
thing you can say about our species
which stretches back to the very
beginning
is that people have always functioned in
multiple groupings
back in the old days it was called
fission fusion
societies i'm talking about the
hunter-gatherer our ancestral
environments we might be in family
groups we might be in hunting groups we
might be in gathering groups
we might gather in tribes always we do
things in different
groupings and do you know we're so good
at that that we can adopt the identity
of that grouping when i go to church
then i'm adopting a certain set of
values and
norms if then i go bowling i'll there'll
be another
set if i'm gonna go to church if uh no
no i'm not religious at all
if i'm uh if i'm in the military then
that will be
uh something else and so uh
we always have had multiple identities
and must
because we live in so many different
contexts but when we talk about identity
politics then a particular identity
sort of trumps the others and
when that identity is a relatively
narrow identity
such as i don't identify myself as a
as a white american or
a lgbt or a
democrat uh whatever if that's my
primary
identity then it's very easy to see
other
well that basically creates an us and
separates the us from
them and very little good can come of
that okay
here's something interesting one you
said that it was a narrow
identity i want to know why is some
people who
pride themselves as being gay or pride
themselves as being black or
pride themselves as being white would
say that's not narrow at all why are you
calling it narrow so i want to know why
are you calling it narrow
and second you said that it's us versus
them but
as far as i know and you can correct me
if i'm wrong in group selection group
selection works when the group
pressures are higher than the individual
pressures for selection but this
this sounds like us versus them is good
for group selection
well it is good for group selection at a
small scale
but part of the dynamic of multi-level
selection is that when i talked about
selfishness within groups being bad for
the group
and the need for group selection for the
group to function well
that gets repeated up the multi-level
hierarchy so a group that functions well
basically can behave selfishly
with respect to other groups you haven't
pro you haven't solved the problem of
selfishness you just elevated it
to the level of the group where it can
take place with more destructive force
than
than ever so that's the sense in which
if your primary identity
is x and that's what you're most eager
to preserve
and to advance then that can cause you
to become opposed
to other identities and now you're back
into a conflictual
situation the only solution to that is
to have a primary identity
which is global ultimately global that's
why at the end of the day
this speaks to the need of creating a
whole earth ethic
basically our group our primary group
should be
the whole earth and our smaller
identities don't disappear
but they need to be coordinated for the
benefit of the largest
entity if our main entity the thing we
care most about is anything smaller than
that
and trump is a great example my america
first he says
uh and of course he'd have to add on any
kind of world stage that if every nation
tries to put themselves first then that
will work out well for the whole planet
he has to say that or otherwise he'd
just be immoral
on the world uh state but the fact is
is that if you have a smaller identity
no matter how large or small if it's
below the
global planetary level and that's the
thing that you truly care about
then almost always that's going to be
disruptive
higher up the scale disruptive for the
planet
and almost always is there instances in
which it's not
uh theoretically it is possible for you
to do something which
which benefits you compared to everyone
else in your group
and benefits the group at the same time
that can happen
but it's very seldom because of the
basic nature of trade-offs
in order to benefit the group it
requires doing certain things
and those things are typically very
different than
what it takes to maximize your relative
position within the group
and i often say this one of my favorite
ways of
explaining this is with the game of
monopoly we all know
the game of monopoly so imagine playing
that game
and of course the goal there is to
capture all the real estate
and drive everyone else bankrupt
that's the goal of monopoly is to
maximize your
relative advantage within the group so
imagine playing that game
and now imagine playing a monopoly
tournament
so now many games are in play and the
trophy goes to the team
that collectively develops their
property the fastest i've changed the
goals of the game
and when i do this in front of an
audience i ask them
and i'll ask the viewers of this of this
of this video so imagine playing that
tournament
and isn't it the case that almost every
decision you make
playing in a tournament would be
different
than the decisions you would make
playing the single game
of monopoly there's your trade-off right
there
that which is required for the group to
function as a coordinated unit
is different than that which is required
for you
to maximize your relative advantage
within the group so it's
seldom the case that the same behavior
would
contribute to both goals that's the
sense in which
in which becoming
[Music]
basically serving one identity is going
to
create problems for
the higher the still higher level good
so there's a very very strong
scientific argument for a whole earth
ethic and i think that all by itself
is a profound insight that emerges from
uh evolution would that work if only
america adopted or only
one country or one continent adopted the
whole earth ethic would that still work
if everybody else is acting selfishly
only one did no and here's
here's another insight that when we talk
about these large large-scale things
like global things
we can get a lot of insight by shrinking
them down
and seeing their similarity to the
dynamics of individuals in small groups
so i'll put your question
i'm going to shrink your question how do
you
in this in a small group if there's only
one cooperator
and everyone else is a defector uh
can cooperation succeed under those
conditions no it cannot
but how many cooperatives do you need
and game theory tells us
there's a whole literature on this that
actually you don't need
too many cooperators to swing things
in the direction of cooperation why is
that
well for one thing the cooperators can
cluster they can interact with each
other
and avoid the depredations of
non-cooperators
they can establish norms and very often
people are willing to do something
that's for the good of the group as long
as they can establish norms
um that um that punish non-cooperative
behavior it's like i'm not willing
here's a good example
let's say that there's something
dangerous that needs to be done by one
person in order to save the group
maybe someone will volunteer but if they
don't let's draw straws
with strong straws it randomizes the
probability that you're going to be the
one
that has to do the dangerous task it's
fair
it's fair so we'll probably agree to
draw straws
even if we might not agree just to
volunteer to
to do something and so there's all kinds
of things that can be established
even at the level of small groups that
can cause everyone to cooperate
even if you're starting out with a
relatively small fraction
of cooperators now we can have having
having thought about this at the small
scale we can
enlarge it back up to the global scale
and you ask the question if only one
nation does this will it work no it
won't
but if there's a critical mass if
there's only one corporation will it
work
no but if there's a critical mass if
there's b corpse
we just learned now that the business
council this this group of uh
of business ceos from all of the
global corporations has met
and made a very important decision
they've decided that they'll no longer
behave just to maximize short-term
profits for their shareholders
they've decided that that actually maybe
wasn't such a good idea maybe they
should have some more sense of
responsibility
towards their stakeholders not their
shareholders their
employees their supply chain their
customers
this fiction that by maximizing the
profits for their
shareholders then that that's some
invisible hand thing takes place and
that
works out for the global good it's just
[ __ ]
which we've known scientifically for a
long time finally the business council
has decided maybe that's that's right
maybe they should
maybe they should do that okay so now we
have some people that are
willing to function excuse me some
corporations that are willing to
function in
in cooperation or maybe something can
come of that
and the same thing with nations is there
something different about
humans or different about our times that
we need this whole earth ethic
because looking outside right now maybe
there's a cricket and it's not thinking
about
the whole earth it's just thinking it
might be thinking about how do i have
sex and how do i
selfishly i don't care about my
neighbors i just want to i want to
procreate
is there something about us now in our
times that we need a whole earth
ethic because that guy doesn't have a
whole earth ethic so what's different
about
us just our power our nuclear power
so there's a number of important things
to uh say about that by the way
is your questions going to be part of
the video yeah
okay good
hello hello testing great okay and that
one's there
and that's great great that's your phone
there's that peter's that's my phone
yeah oh that's your phone okay okay
okay so the question was what the heck
is different about
us compared to some animals because i'm
sure
animals aren't thinking how do i
benevolently help the earth they don't
even have a conception of the earth but
yet
you're advocating for a whole earth
ethic for us so there's
i think two main things to say about
that there's a number of major ideas
that are still
quite prevalent but are pre-darwinian
they're false ideas one idea in
economics
is that there's some kind of natural
order
that if everyone just pursues their
self-interest
and they're led as if by an invisible
hand to benefit the common
good that implies that there's some kind
of self-organized
system that works well and that we
unknowingly play our parts
so so that's one idea but
there's a parallel idea in biology which
is sort of harmony in nature that nature
left by itself
strikes some kind of balance and so
ecosystems for example
have some sort of design or harmony
to them that's an idea in biology which
is quite
similar to ideas and economics and
they're both profoundly
false false um evolution doesn't make
any
everything nice and so if you look out
there
at the great outdoors what you find is
ecosystems collection of species
and those species are all pursuing their
adaptive strategies
all the crickets are trying to get laid
and the fish are trying to get laid and
the birds and the bees are trying to get
laid and
and survive and so on and so forth how
does that settle out at the level of the
whole collective
the ecosystem not necessarily harmonious
and nowadays and so the balance of
nature that concept
is something which has been rejected and
what
is more true is often called
ecological regimes and that
i think is so evocative because if you
look at what the word regime means in
human
social systems when we call something a
regime
there has to be a bit of stability about
it a regime is something which is going
to
hang around a while we wouldn't call it
a regime if it was just transient
so it's stable but is it a good regime
a bad regime is it a corrupt regime a
despotic regime
an enlightened regime its stability
does not tell us about its quality as
some kind of
system that we might want to live in and
so what you find in nature
are regimes there's collections of
species that are
kind of stable
but are they good do they recycle
nutrients well or poorly
and what you find is is that many
ecological regimes many communities
are out there are despotic in
human terms there's one dominant species
that's bullying the other
species poisoning its environment
let us say and the same is true for
single species societies many
social species if you look at their
societies they're horrible societies and
in human terms they're just dominated by
individuals trying to
they're like the single game of monopoly
we'd never want to live in those
in those societies and so
nature does not provide some kind of
simplistic
model of harmony and cooperation
not single species social systems and
not
multi-species communities there are in
nature
some ecosystems and some single species
communities that work extraordinarily
well
as societies we have our microbiomes
we also have the social insects that
we've known about for a long time your
ants your bees your termites
your wasps those function as colonies
extremely well because they've been
selected as
at the colony at the colony level
and so i think really if we if we search
for a religious doctrine it should be
the buddhist doctrine
the four noble truths which begins with
life is suffering
if we look out there in human life and
in the biological world we see primarily
suffering why
because of greed and striving we're all
striving to
accomplish our lower level goals
and that's what's producing suffering
higher up the scale is there a solution
yes is there a path
yes there is and what might that be
it is basically a recognition
that if we want to benefit the whole
system
then we have to lose our attachment to
the self
okay and we have to work on behalf
of the whole system is actually quite a
impressive mapping of buddhist thought
onto
evolutionary thought that's very
interesting thing to uh
to uh to think about
got him wow oh i wish that on camera
yeah
okay so let's get back to this so you
said that if i'm hearing correctly there
are regimes
in other words stable groups and just
because they have lasted for a long time
it doesn't mean
good it doesn't mean they are good and
good is defined as the opposite of bad
and bad is defined as
selfishly power hungry something like
that if you look at human history
you find basically
multi-level selection operating at
various
scales what defines us as a species
is our ability to cooperate at the scale
of small groups i think that
one of the amazing discoveries of
recent evolutionary thought is that we
are
a a eu social species in a sense or an
ultra-social
species in some ways we are like a
beehive
that's how cooperative we are in small
and small small group so we achieved a
degree of
of within group harmony uh
always protected always guarded and
vigilant it's not as if we're noble
savages it's that we're able to hold
each other
in check we have a very strong sense
that we're moral equals basically and
that therefore you shouldn't
beat up on me that's a bad thing to do
and we have the collective ability to
gang up
on would-be bullies and so now that puts
us into team mode
and the whole concept of morality the
whole concept of morality could be
understood as a set of mechanisms
that cause us to function cooperatively
in relatively small groups
and so nevertheless
when it came to between group
interactions anything goes and anything
means
not just warfare but trade and
and forms of cooperation and the full
range of ecological interactions that
take place between species
also took place among small human groups
including warfare big time warfare so
so competition between groups violent or
otherwise
is joined at the hip with cooperation
within groups so suffering didn't go
away
it just took place more at the level of
between group interactions
than within group interactions
can you explain that suffering didn't go
away just took place at the level of
between group interactions so the
individual wasn't suffering what do you
mean
well individuals
there's one person involved in this uh
richard mangum who's
one of the anthropologists who studied
chimpanzees for a long long
time has a new book out called the
goodness paradox
a great book and
[Music]
not as good as this view of life thank
you thank you
um but um and he talks among other
things about self-domestication
which is a fascinating topic in its own
right so when we domesticate species we
select them mostly for their tameness
but do you know a lot of other stuff
comes along with it and there's a whole
fascinating story
about how selecting for the behavior of
tameness
also selects for all sorts of
physiological uh
traits so and that's a that's kind of
another
uh story but in the same the same way
that we've domesticated many species
uh we've also domesticated ourselves
basically we've selected ourselves for
tameness another way to retell the story
that i just told
is that in a group where people are able
there's a relatively equal balance of
power people to
hold each other in check then if you're
a big bastard
that's trying to get your way ultimately
we'll just kill you
and before that we'll have other
sanctions which are going to limit your
reproductive success and that's like
selecting ourselves for tameness
okay so now we are docile in a way
um that chimps aren't so
rangham who should know says that if you
look at the level of aggression within
groups the kind of interaction where i
just
fly into a rage and just beat the [ __ ]
out of you
and we're a member of the same community
that happens
in a chimp community a hundred or a
thousand times more frequently
than in a small scale society if you
live within a small scale
human society you'd never see that you
see people getting along pretty
well and so that means they're not
imposing suffering on each other
within groups very much very much
yet they're still suffering when we go
on a raid
to another group and we kill somebody
and steal their women and
we do all that kind of or maybe
exterminate them
entirely so yes they're suffering and
it's self-imposed suffering but it's
being imposed at the level
of groups now if you look at the last
ten thousand years of human history
and here my colleague peter turchen
takes over with his book ultra society
the last 10 000 years of what's it
called again
it's called ultra society how ten
thousand years of warfare turned us into
the greatest cooperators on earth
uh what you find is basically the same
thing at ever increasing
scales with the advent of agriculture
and the fact that we're a cultural
species of the whole
genetic evolution of cultural evolution
and we actually need to be getting to
that because it gets to such things as
archetypes and
memes and the whole fact that in our
species
there's a cultural stream of evolution
in addition to a genetic
stream of evolution and all of that is
a matter of cooperation also so if we
didn't evolve to be a cooperative
species
but could we could not have evolved the
ability to transmit
large amounts of learned information
across generations
through symbolic systems
systems of symbolic thought so
everything distinctive about our species
including our
capacity for symbolic thought and our
ability to transmit large amounts of
information across cultures
all of that was only made possible
thanks to the fact that we became highly
cooperative
we cooperate in physical activities and
we cooperate in mental activities
as a result we began to generate our own
resources
scale of human society increased and now
that's been a process um that's taken us
to the present
moment of huge societies of hundreds of
millions and even billions of
individuals
operating in a way that is um
amazingly cooperative on an average day
if you go out luckily for us
you won't see people imposing a lot of
suffering
well you won't see anything because
there's nothing for miles out here
so so um
so another answer to your question is
that the scale of society has become so
big that that basically we're now having
a planetary impact that we didn't have
before there's no escape from that and
so
that of course is is something that
uh cultural evolution has been building
towards
but uh now more than ever before we are
uh
having a planetary impact that requires
us to have a whole earth ethic before
that there would be externalities
and then and that would not be quite as
dominating as they are now but now we're
we're really in a situation where if we
don't act at the planetary scale then
we're toast
so that is what's in front of us
i'm just going to try and restate what
you said we grew up in
small social groups so we've been
selected somewhat for
cooperative behavior now our small
groups became medium-sized groups and
then large groups and now we're so
technologically powerful that our
mistakes are causing the destruction of
the entire planet and therefore we need
to adopt
a new ethic is that
a good summation or is there something
that's missing it's not a bad summation
a new ethic is basically a more global
ethic i think that
quite an important thing to say because
it's in contrast to
orthodox economic thought if you take
someone like friedrich hayek
he would say that that who was actually
very evolutionary for his day
that there was basically we have our
tribal values you know we operate in
small groups and we have that whole kind
of system but
a modern economic system has to be
something very different
and that's what the market economy is
and that's where the invisible hand
comes from the idea that
we can all pursue our lower level
self-interest and it'll
magically uh benefit the
common uh good now
although market economies are huge and
very important and so on although they
have to be much better much better
regulated make no mistake
really what it seems is that we need to
take those tribal values
that and we need to scale them up
scale them up they're not different they
just have to be
operating at a larger scale at the level
of nations and global corporations
within the global village for example
so their interactions are a little
different than
interactions of individuals in our
groups as i said earlier
in this conversation let's take these
big problems and shrink them down
see what they look like for individuals
in a small group then we can expand them
back up and what you see they're the
same problems
and so so we need to we we have to have
a moral system that moral system has to
include all of us
it has to be a planetary moral system we
have to be solid citizens
ourselves and then we have to hold
others in
check and we have to do that as nations
and and multinational corporations and
we use the genius of the of technology
and the internet to give us a nervous
system
we need it it's essential for for that
uh yes there has to be market processes
but they have to be much better
regulated and oriented towards the
common uh common good so it's the same
way of thinking the same values
the great challenge is to expand their
scale this may sound foolish but why is
it a challenge
if we were selected for it why isn't it
natural to us
that is um
actually a deeper question than you
might think or maybe you thought i
already thought it was a deep question
but
i think all my questions are deep
questions here's i think our
fascinating uh
question that might seem tangential but
can relate
do women have breast do women have
instincts for breastfeeding
isn't it curious that when bottle
feeding became available so many women
jumped say well that's a good idea
and they didn't have any sort of
instinct for breastfeeding it
it seems well that actually makes sense
when you realize that there was never
any alternative
so why do you need an instinct for
something where there's no
alternative there's a sense where uh
life in small groups
do we have instincts for for living in
in small groups in a sense yes but
there's also a sense in which
there was never any alternative until
the last
10 000 years and so now
and this is what i spend most of my time
doing scientifically is studying
groups of all sizes including small
groups but do you know that if you look
at small groups in modern life
and you ask how old do they function um
they vary hugely they don't all function
well if you put people in a small
group they don't always function they
don't just click like that as if we have
as if we have as we're naturally
predisposed to it
what's that as if we're naturally
predisposed as if we're not now we are
make no mistake
when we get to archetypes and and
evolutionary psychology
this is i mean it's not a black and
white thing yes we do have instincts
that
are brought into play we do have a
strong sense of
morality for example of egalitarianism
we don't like to be pushed around
when we see this behavior we tend to
punish italy some of us
do and these things are to some extent
sort of out of the box
okay so we have a very complicated
evolved
psychology that includes the psychology
of moral systems and
so on and so forth but for some reason
that is not enough for when you compose
a group in in in modern life where it's
just to
just to immediately click into place
um one reason is of course is that
we've always been playing the
multi-level
game our evolve psychology basically
puts us in the position of of
functioning in cooperative mode of
exploitation
well there's more than one way to
survive and reproduce by cooperating or
by exploiting
so everyone to some extent has plan a
and plan
b and when you see a group isn't
functioning well it's often because some
individuals within the group
are getting their way working for them
it's just not working for everyone else
and so that's the dynamic of
multi-level selection weighing in favor
of
the lower level disruptive process
basically people are playing and winning
the single game of monopoly they're not
playing in a monopoly
tournament but
it's sufficiently unstated
unexamined basically that you
can go to any kind of group and you can
examine it you could look at the
variation
and then you could make it function
better by
by basically cultivating a more explicit
awareness about evolution
multi-level selection and so on and so
forth to
to then
get the group to function in in
monopoly tournament mode more than a
single game of monopoly mode
i have a couple questions one is a
slightly union question you was asked
i think it was carl jung why can't i
just
do what's good for me at the expense of
others and then carly was like what give
me an example he can't
he said you can't do that he said that
you have the more you realize that
you're
inextricably linked with the world well
actually that's correct the more you
realize that the better your life will
be
that person said why why can't i just
eat cheetos
and play video games and then he said
that's not actually good for you that's
good for you maybe
for one week or maybe two weeks or maybe
a month but the longer you look out in
time you have to take into account other
people because you're going to interact
with them
and then you also have to take into
account your environment because you're
going to interact with your environment
and so you have to act in what would
traditionally be seen as noble or what
you call virtuous
if you want to benefit yourself across
time so just matters
like you were talking about the
corporations if they prioritize
short-term profits that not that's not
necessarily good
but you included in a key word
short-term
so what if you think about long-term so
then the question is how long is long
but my question is in this union sense
what he was saying
you look out across time let's say your
life span let's say 60 years maybe even
100 you
incorporate your grandchildren into it
then is it not true
that the self the more the more
selfishly we act
the more it jives with what's good for
the group because i can't just screw you
that's actually not good for me i'm
gonna have a bad reputation
okay there's a lot to unpack here you're
attributing to
jung something which actually gets
replicated again and again and again
this idea that the uh
the most enlightened form of
self-interest is cooperation
then if you're selfish in the pejorative
sense of the word benefiting yourself at
the expense of
others well that's not even going to
work out for you over the long term so
really you should be cooperating
and so that's a line of thought which
has been replicated again and again and
again
and of course it's very normative
most recently i've encountered this in
the writing of alexi de tocqueville
the french social theorist who visited
america in the 1830s
and commented compared his nation of
france with the new
democratic uh experiment and his phrase
was self-interest
rightly understood and it was quite
fascinating because he
he was he actually was noting a cultural
trend it was very
prescient that um in the old
aristocratic days when people talked
about virtue and
sacrifice and things like that they
actually did not frame it in terms of
enlightened self-interest but now
tocqueville said with all of the
democratic revolutions in america and
france and so on increasingly everything
was being
framed in terms of self-interest we
don't do anything unless we see it as a
form of
self-interest and that being the case we
have to distinguish between
self-interest rightly understood which
is cooperation
as opposed to self-interest wrongly
understood which leads to all kind of
shitty
outcomes outcomes so tocqueville was
saying exactly the same thing that you
represented jung is saying and it's been
said a thousand times before so
basically
is there something wrong with it it's uh
hold on it's an argument of
it's an argument for cooperation framed
in terms of self-interest
and in order to do that it must
distinguish between for
between different kinds of self-interest
the rightly understood kind
and the wrongly understood kind even
iran the
high priestess of selfishness
distinguished between rational and
irrational forms
of self-interest you can't talk about
self-interest on the
on any kind of stage without actually
making this distinction and talking
about moral forms of self-interest
as opposed to immoral forms of
self-interest so
so it's good advice you might say that
if everyone took it then they'd be
cooperate
okay but really it does not describe
i mean if it fails in a number of ways
other than a
other than a good advice a feel-good
story a nice aspirational narrative
it fails in a whole bunch of
a whole bunch of of of ways and let me
try to begin to
to uh list them for one thing
it ignores the fact that
evolution is based on relative fitness
when it comes to evolution it does not
matter how well you survive
and reproduce in absolute terms
only compared to others
in your vicinity and the whole appeal of
enlightened self-interest as you
described it
if you're young i describe it through
toefl it's basically framed in terms of
absolute
self-interest if you're self-interested
and rightly understood this will work
out
better for you than if it's
self-interest wrongly
understood you if you do this will do
better than you if you don't do
that that's not relative fitness the
question is how well am i going to do
compared to my competitors
others in my vicinity that's the
question we should be asking
no it's the question of the way the
human mind is
and so when people actually operate very
often they're trying to get positional
advantage
okay that's how we operate
and it's not wrong i mean basically we
do need to worry about our relative
fitness that means that if i what's
enlightened is to make sure
that we all do something that's
cooperative okay
we're all working towards cooperative
solutions make no mistake
about that but when you look at how the
human mind actually
operates there's two things you can say
about it
it privileges positional advantage
and short-term
gain as opposed to long-term gain we've
all learned about discounting the future
that a benefit now is going to be
more important than that same benefit
delayed in time why is it is because i
might not live that long
and so especially when you put people in
precarious situations
existentially insecure situations their
minds
are going to privilege
immediate gain
and if you tell them immediate relative
gain immediate relative
gain and if you tell them they'll be
better in the long term
[ __ ] as far as what they need to do
and what their minds are telling them to
do
in order to survive another day in order
to survive another day
and one of my colleagues robert frank an
economist
a well-regarded economist
wrote a book called the darwin economy
in which he makes this
very uh point he says a hundred years
from now i hope it doesn't take that
long
darwin not adam smith will be regarded
as the father
of economics and the main difference is
that economists as
i've just said they posit
the national actor homo economicus
the utility maximizer only wants to
maximize its absolute utility
not in reference to anyone else as if we
only want to be wealthy in some absolute
sense
not in comparison to anyone else well no
one works like that
the only reason you want to have a
thousand dollar suit is to look better
than someone with a five hundred dollar
suit life is about relative
advantage and yet economic theory has
not framed that
that way so that's the sense in which an
appeal to enlighten self-interest
it's it's a nice aspirational message
but really it
it it it misses all of the complications
that we've just been talking about
do you mean to say it's correct in that
if we followed it it would be great it's
just not
motivating enough
he said it sounds nice in terms of
aspirations or inspirations but it's not
it's not it doesn't capture it in game
theory terms and this this
this holds for all efforts to make
people more cooperative whether you
frame it in terms of self-interest or
not
if we encourage people to be altruistic
or cooperative
and we motivate it in any way that moves
them it might be an appeal to
self-interest
or it might be some other appeal to
empathy or
whatever so then they go out in the
world
and they're nice but it turns out
that the people with whom they interact
are not necessarily
nice so what happens then
what happens on the basis of the advice
that you
gave them they're going to become losers
because they're you you release them
into a social environment in which
in which cooperation is not the most
successful
strategy and so we have to be smarter
than that it's actually unethical to
counsel someone to be nice
and then put them in a social
environment where niceness doesn't
pay so this is why we have to be much
more systemic we have to create social
environments
that actually causes niceness to win the
darwinian
contest and if we don't do that we go
my colleagues and i call this declawing
the cat the alley cat
you don't take an alley cat remove its
claws and put it back in an
alley why would you do something like
that and why would the cat
actually take your advice and yet if you
create a social environment that
actually protects niceness which is what
a moral system does
then most people will take a look at
that and they'll say
okay it's safe to be nice now and
they'll be safe that's really nice
are you using nice as a synonym for
virtue or using nice just
let me give cooperative strategies
nice means is that i'm going to do well
by you
i'll be a cooperator because it could
also mean courage
standing up for what you think is right
not being a pushover
all of those giving when you think about
nice is not like a patsy strategy nice
can be
there's tough forms of niceness but uh
but no it's what's it's what's
what's best for all of us it's my wife
sorry that's all right do you want to
see if you can get that flying
sure because you're an expert at that so
i think that's your true color actually
it's my wife who's the real expert but
and you know she studies birds and she
actually catches birds in nets like this
and
it's like quidditch it's just amazing i
was wondering about the books
i said the bird books yeah why do we
take a little break and
you mentioned that we would need to
take our tribalism and apply to the
globe now when i hear people say what's
wrong with us
it's tribalism that the left the radical
left and the alt-right
are taking us to our tribal roots but
you're saying tribalism
might be the answer so are we using the
same word to describe two different
things or do you have a different view i
i mean there's many ways to skin the
somatic cat but i think that tribalism
is just fine as long as we regard
ourselves as part of a global tribe then
there we are
we do need a strong sense of us but let
it be everyone
and also um nature
as well so let that be our tribe i think
that might be one of the most intuitive
ways to
to um to describe it and we're so
flexible about our social identities
that's another thing that needs to be
said all of our social identities are
socially
constructed we imagine our groups and
then we function
within them and so that means it's not
so much of a stretch of the imagination
to think of ourselves as part of
a global tribe
not hard you mentioned that you had some
problems with the social
constructionists and i want to know
first of all if you could define what
social constructivism is and then
what do you see as its problems
well i wrote an essay a while back
called evolutionary social
constructivism
which said that social constructivism
isn't wrong
it just has to be approached from an
evolutionary
perspective most social constructivists
see themselves
as opposed to evolutionary
thinking this goes back to the days of
sociobiology when ed wilson
wrote the book sociobiology in 1975
and he was branded as
being a genetic determinist and the
alternative to sociobiology
was social constructivism it was the
idea that we are a cultural species that
we um
were very flexible basically were
capable of coming up with any behavior
any
social arrangement and this was thought
to be an opposition
to sociobiology
now what we can say is yes we are a
cultural species
and we do construct our social
environments so we are very flexible not
infinitely flexible but very flexible in
what we can become as individuals and
and
societies but all of that is a matter of
cultural evolution
and so we need to expand evolutionary
thinking beyond genetic evolution
to include cultural evolution and it's
at that point that
social constructivism will be seen
as a evolutionary topic and the term
niche construction
which is a term that originated within
evolutionary
theory is basically another word for
social
construction at least in the human
human case so yes we are
cultural species we do construct our
societies but please don't think that
as something which is somehow outside
the orbit of
evolutionary thinking what are the
problems that you have with
post-modernists if any
i think that i actually look for
the baby in the bathwater of most
traditions
one phrase that i like from an
evolutionist named aj kane is that
only the simplest mind can believe that
in a great controversy one side is mere
folly and so when smart people disagree
then there's probably a baby somewhere
in the bath water but then of course
there's also
the bathwater and so postmodernism
social constructivism
all of these things i think part of the
baby
what's legitimate is
what's called a thick description of a
given culture
recognition that a culture is something
which is very com
complicated and has to be understood in
some kind of
contextual way and all of that is great
because it's true
so i love that part but also there's
in some ways often the bath water
is a denial of anything that can count
as objective
reality that there's no such thing as
objective facts for example
that the the kind of body of facts that
we associate with science has no more
authority than any other cultural
construction and so i think that when we
talk about now in the post-truth society
and and fake news and a president that
basically lies
every day of his life um
is in some sense attributed to the
postmodern
tradition which became anti-anti-science
and you know in in
um in the humanities in anthropology and
and linguistics and and cultural studies
uh very much cleaves along lines of uh
of a branch that is more or less science
friendly
and and a branch which is uh science uh
um unfriendly and and so what we've lost
what we've lost not everywhere but um
um in many in many contexts
is this idea that there's um
there's facts of the world that we have
to that we have to discover and
and and hold each other uh
accountable to um i have another quote
from the dalai lama that i love
which is that um
anyone who defies the authority of
empirical evidence is not worthy of
critical engagement in a dialogue
if you're just making stuff up and if
you're denying
what's out there you're not worth
talking to is what that
is what that means and so i need we need
to recover the idea that there is a
world out there
it's independent of our own meaning
systems our own symbolic systems and
that creates a challenge of somehow
our meaning systems whatever they are
whether they're religious or not
everyone has one
and it is not a direct reflection of the
real world but nevertheless there is a
real world out there
and we can apprehend it using the tools
that we typically associate with
science and so and so that has to be
part of the
part of the um operating
rules for our for our discourse it has
to be science based
but it also has to be smart about how
difficult it is for us to
um apprehend the the real world and how
tempted we are
at a deep psychological level in making
stuff up
that supports our world
views there's a deep statement there
about epistemology basically the nature
of knowledge from
an evolutionary perspective evolution as
transformative things to say about
about ethics and morality and
epistemology all of the major branches
of philosophy
what do you think of the post-modern
inspired fields like women's studies
gender studies
sex fat studies sexual studies what do
you think of
the idea that they're putting forth that
separates us
into different groups and then therefore
our tribal circuitry quote-unquote
tribal circuitry is being
hijacked and now it's us versus them in
different groups i know we've talked
about this earlier
what do you think of that is that true
what is this tribal circuitry that's
being
triggered can you first expand on the
tribal circuitry that some
evolutionary biologists talk about
obviously we can't speak for them but
whatever you think that term means
what is this tribal circuitry and how
are these
other disciplines
utilizing that for something that's not
necessarily good for the whole
so again let's talk about the baby
before we talk about the
bath water the baby of these
identities is that they're pointing out
that the mainstream worldview
is in fact extremely provincial
it's the world view of a certain
privileged
culture say white european male
culture is interpreting reality for
everyone
when in fact it's extremely provincial
and
ultimately self-serving
and you know i think you know that
there's an acronym that's been coined
weird a white educated industrial
rich and democratic which is
the dominating culture that's what i
think you're referring to as western
culture and it interprets itself
as human nature and the human condition
and this term was coined by my colleague
joseph penric at harvard
university and it's getting a lot of
attention now because
so much research that's done primarily
in western nations
and in with college students or even
when it's done internationally
it's done in those segments of the
population that have thoroughly bought
into western market
economies so much psychological research
and
research of all kinds has been done on
this narrow slice
of humanity and and it's not general
it's not general at all and so it's a
major
initiative now which is gaining steam is
that if you want to say something about
human nature you cannot confine it
to weird people
people weird societies so just now on
twitter you get
for example a result that came out of
research is that
you know in any population x percent our
cooperators
y presenter defectors whatever
and um
did you get it oh i thought i did
man i should have no that's all right
um so you're saying that there's
research on twitter not on twitter it's
being reported on
on twitter this was thought to be very
very general many many studies show that
there's the same kind of breakdown of
cooperators and defectors and uh and uh
hold on a minute
and um this is too terribly distracting
isn't it oh it's okay you can do it
come on little guy i'll just move a
little bit
and i'll get you come on come on
got him so there's some research that's
popularized on twitter as being
also the ultimate also the ultimatum
game the famous ultimating game i give
you ten dollars
and you can share a portion with a
second person
and that second person their only choice
is to accept your offer
or to or to reject it in which case
nobody gets anything
and economic wisdom held that the first
person should
should share as little as possible but
knowing that the second person would
take
anything over nothing at all that's the
economic wisdom
uh the result of the actual experiment
is is that no people have a sense of
fairness
and unless the offer is fair the person
would rather have nothing
than to accept an unfair offer
and so this was the new normal was that
that's the way homo
sapiens is well come to find out and
this is actually the work of joseph
henrik
is that when he played that same
ultimatum game in societies around the
world including small-scale
societies he found tons of variation
all kinds of variation that was
unexplained and so that was what it
meant to go beyond weird societies
to sample the richness of
human cultural diversity
so if we get back to identity politics
what you have is basically members of
the population
which are marginalized they might come
from
cultural traditions historically that
are not part of western culture or they
might come from western
cultural traditions but marginalized
people such as women or
or gays or or anyone who's being
shamed or whatever okay and their
experience is very
different and they want you to know that
so basically they are claiming
authentically that the world as seen
through the eyes of
privileged people is not actually the
world that they experience and they're
also
claiming justice that
they they need to be more
fully participants in a moral society
and both of those things can be
correct so that's a pretty big baby in
the bathwater
identity politics
if it becomes highly divisive there has
to be some sense in which there's a we
that we can become a part of and if you
lose out of that then it becomes only
conflictual
so there must be some working towards
a um a uh
a larger scale of of uh of cooperation
so can you describe this tribal
circuitry
what is it when certain biologists say
there's a tribal
part of our brain and when we're divided
up into groups we are
hijacking that or we're turning it on
and now we're against them
what is that what do they mean well i
think that i would be
more or less in agreement with what many
people would say to that that
we're such a group living species that
we're always looking for
who's us who's the what is the group
that i'm in
and that i'm supposed to be a member of
and supposed to be
cooperating that's what
and we all we all need that just in
order to function in any particular
in any particular context the salience
of the tribe
grows with the stakes basically for
survival and and reproduction so
if you're uh if you in a really
existentially insecure situation
where your own life is threatened for
example or the life of your people
is threatened then that psychology of
being
a member of a group and that group being
threatened
is becomes more and more and more uh
salient and my colleague michelle
gelfind
wrote a book called rulemakers rule
breakers and she does research on
on a continuum of cultural variation
which
from tight to loose so a tight culture
is one that has very strong norms that
are
enforced by punishment if you're a
member of that culture then you are
expected to do certain things and if you
don't
then there will be big consequences
okay a loose culture is much more
flexibility in what you can
do a lot more elbow room in which you
want to do to explore your own options
and so on and that continuum from tight
to loose
more or less is adapted to an
environmental continuum of existential
security
so if life is safe and secure life is
good nobody's threatening
us then why shouldn't we explore our
options the optimal social arrangement
for a safe and secure environment is a
loose
culture but if it's really life or death
then we have to have extreme solidarity
and what you do you've got to do this
you have to be part of us and so on and
so forth you also have to prepare to
sacrifice
your life if if
necessary and so you're not free to
to do this or or or that
and so um that
cultural continuum and its underlying
environmental
basis explains a lot it also explains
that the more
things go wrong in modern life that's
essentially insecure
things are the more we become tight in
our psychological
orientation and we find it very
difficult to be flexible accepting of
other positions and so on
and so forth so paradoxically if we want
to
cultivate a safe and secure environment
and a loose culture which in some ways i
think you could say a loose culture
is better than a tight culture because
of the environmental condition that's
a safe and secure environment is better
than a dangerous
environment so uh
so one reason why things have become
worse
culturally and more divisive culturally
is because they've become more
existentially
insecure and that i think this explains
for example
when we talk about the right um
and nationalistic movements and so on
and so forth i mean the reasons are
plain enough
members of many societies feel that
they're not they're not sharing the
benefits of the
of the society if you're in france or
england or or whatever and you're just a
an average bloke in the
and and then you see immigrants coming
in and taking jobs and you don't have a
very good
job it's what's not working for you the
global european union's not working for
for you why shouldn't you stand up for
something that's more recognizable as
your
as your uh people so i think in
many ways and this is not original a lot
of the problems associated with this
fragmentation is
is based on such things as extreme
inequality
the global order including the european
union and
and and all of that it's not it's not
it's not working well for the average
why should they be invested
in it what's in it for them and so
there's some sense in which the solution
has to be
um a uh
result in in some of these global
problems of
of uh income inequality of
unregulated capitalism if we don't solve
that problem
then we shouldn't expect these solutions
to these other
problems you mentioned existential
security
and you're saying that the higher the
level of inequality
the less existential security we have
yes
and that's in part because back to
relative fitness it doesn't really
matter that we're
affluent we compare ourselves
with others there's a lot of research
knowing that how
how good you feel with your about your
life it depends on
[Music]
your lot compared to others a lot of
ills are attributed
to so how do we get over that if that's
so ingrained in us
and also why was that selected for if we
were selected in these small groups
where cooperation was the norm well in
those groups there was there was
a um wasn't the kind of unfair
inequality
that uh that exists today in the first
place there's a strong sense of
egalitarianism where we're all
equal i'm not better than you and
also there wasn't a lot of difference in
material
wealth at that time and if someone was
given a leadership role it was based on
their contribution
to the group yes you'll be your leader
and yet that might make you wealthier
and
so on and so forth but unless you're
actually serving us in some
in some sense then then we won't follow
you
anymore much more bottom-up control of
those societies than you might
than you might think and even big man
societies and societies that look
hierarchical
actually it was like a a almost like a
banking system in which the wealth of
the society was accumulated
in certain families for example or
temples or something like that
but it was shared out it was almost like
a distribution
and that worked in the small scale
system that worked for those
times in and
and and places so so
um if you look at modern nations
and um the ones that work best and the
nordic countries come up again and again
as the
nations that function best in in
modern life and whenever this gets
discussed then americans are
insist that there's no way that you can
compare those countries with
america they're too homogenous all this
kind of stuff which is that
why is that not a good critique that
they're too homogeneous
homogeneity i mean might play some
goal but it's small
compared to the equality that's built
into those
countries in the first place they're not
culturally homogenous i
i study norway quite extensively
norway is a mountainous country and
mountainous countries
always have the effect of cultural
diversity
right look at new guinea every valley
and so if you look at norway
two or three hundred years ago there
were so many little dialects
in each and every one of those little
mountains they weren't even speaking the
same language
someone from southern norway couldn't
understand someone in
northern how's that culturally
homogeneous and you had the vikings and
all these things they're all warring
with each other
so it makes a little sense to say that
there's some
mysterious kind of cultural um
homogeneity uh again it's not as if that
that's
there's nothing to that but for the most
part it has to do with the fact that
there's
that they've managed to scale up the
equality and
and uh well there's much to say but
we can leave it there for the moment
earlier we were doing a thought
experiment
we're trying to solve the large scale
problems by by imagining it in a small
scale
well if we were to imagine our
some of our problems with regard to
income inequality on the global scale
then we shrink it down to the small
scale and we think about how did this
work when it was
with tribes but then we said we just
established actually that doesn't work
because there are no examples of it
working
there are no examples of extreme
inequality within a group of
well what you find in very small scale
societies is that they don't allow that
kind of
income disparity if somebody
has a windfall or like especially like
they
kill a large game or something like that
it's scrupulously
shared but it was with the advent of
agriculture that that began to change
and um and as a result
societies became more despotic this was
something that peter turchin
chronicles in his book ultra
ultra society so that whenever you do
have an
a large imbalance of power then it does
tend to
corrupt the ability to cooperate within
that
uh society and that will happen
it happens all the time there's a
inevitable
tendency for it to happen power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts
absolutely and the main preventative for
that
is between group competition
a despotic society can work to a degree
but there's a point at which you cannot
just
bully people into cooperating with you
and so if there's some other society
over here that offers a better deal to
its
members and they will collectively beat
the more despotic society and that's
true to this day if you measure modern
societies
for their degree of equality there's
books like
the spirit level these are famous books
and political science
why nations fail these are books that
show
that nations vary in their degree of
inclusiveness
and the inclusive ones work better than
the
what about the nordic countries as far
as i know their laws when it comes to
immigration
is tighter than americas so
first we have to look at the societies
as they exist as
societies before we talk about the very
recent problem
of of uh immigration and i'm not
romanticizing those countries in fact
there's a very close affinity
between the nordic countries and germany
and there's a strong thread of racial
superiority in the kind of the aryan
uh mentality that exists in those um
in those countries and so there's a
whole modern set of problems about
immigration and also
how much a country can can
um
immigrants so i mean these are real
issues that have to be taken
taken very seriously the point i want to
make about norway or the scandinavian
countries and not just them but you can
count switzerland and switzerland is not
culturally homogenous they speak four
languages within the same
nation the netherlands japan pick any
country that works well
often with histories which were highly
unequal
take japan as a feudal so i took england
as a
feudal society before it became
democratic but if you understand why
they're working well it's because they
have
actually managed to have a
relatively egalitarian relationship
which in a modern context means that
basically
labor capital
and government all have a lot of power
and work cooperatively collaboratively
for the common good that's what you see
a strong labor sector strong capital
sector strong government sector
and a cooperative spirit that for what
are we going to do as a
as a nation those are the ingredients
and they're the same shrinking back down
as a group whose members have a
relatively equal balance of power
and are trying to do well for the whole
group
that's what's needed and that's what
actually describes the best periods of
american history
the new deal the so-called era of good
feelings in the 1980s
i mean there really is a formula that's
not hard to understand
about the need for equality to force
for cooperation to to work at any scale
is there a connection between a whole
earth ethic or this cooperation
idea that you're putting forward
cooperation is essentially
is there a connection between that and
communism as some people might say
i know that now i don't know too much
about this but i know that some people
were
suggesting that group selection group
favorite selection
is evidence towards communism being the
correct
political mode versus capitalism which
sounds to be
more individual yeah so uh i think that
that's actually
not the right way to think about it and
why is that not correct
because every system whether it's a
socialist system or a
capitalist system is
or should be designed to work well as a
system
and so capitalism claims to be better as
a system
for the benefit of all capitalism does
not say
who cares about the benefit of all i'm
just going to go rich
right and so in that sense
everyone's a socialist in the sense that
if they argue for some kind of political
philosophy it has to work well at the
society
level otherwise you couldn't call it you
could even
discuss it if it if you weren't
presenting something that worked well at
the societal
level and so what we have to do is we
have to compare the societies that have
been
guided by capitalism and societies that
have been guided by
communism and we have to ask how well do
they work
as societies and what you discovered
there
is that the
socialist experiments actually
work very poorly very poorly
all the way up to venezuela uh
in the current in the current time so
why do they work so badly
for two main reasons
uh and here i'm relying on a great
scholar of
economics and and uh
and political theory named jeffrey
hodgson
in the um in the um in the uk
um so one reason they work poorly is
that centralized planning
uh they rejected the idea of
of market economies which uh hayek got
something
right basically and the market economy
is a a great way for adjusting prices
um to accommodate values to a
to a degree and if you actually try to
plan everything centrally it will never
work because the society is too complex
so here complexity comes in as a as an
important body of theory in addition to
in addition to evolution centralized
planning
doesn't work because the systems are too
complex for any group of experts to work
out and implement
a grand plan centralized planning
doesn't work
it doesn't even work at the level of a
small company not to speak of an
of a nation and the other problem with
socialism is that power gets
concentrated in the hands of
an elite a small group of elites
and whenever you get an imbalance of
power then basically you get that kind
of corruption where they
they run the country for their benefit
not for the benefit of the whole
country so between power being
concentrated
and centralized planning um all social
all experiments they're
called socialists have failed miserably
okay so now let's look at capitalism
and they also fail
do they fail as badly well i don't care
they fail in ways that we need to
correct and they fail basically
by
buying into the invisible hand metaphor
by thinking that the pursuit of lower
level self-interest
in an ugly unregulated economy if we
just try to maximize our wealth
and corporations just trying to maximize
their their
their profits that's their only
responsibility as friedman said the only
social responsibility of a company is to
earn profits for its uh
shareholders that's a recipe for
disaster
so both of those don't work and now we
have to then we can discuss what can
can work when we were talking about
existential security
you were saying that there's titan loose
which i associate with totalitarianism
and liberalism is that a wrong
association
no that'd be pretty good okay
okay is strong existential security
needed for liberalism or does liberalism
produce
existential security
i would like to think that um
what we associate with liberalism and
democratic governance and so on can
function in very harsh environments
in some ways it's needed more than ever
and uh
actually there's great um um
uh destroyers to be
to be told there i mentioned the book
why nations fail by uh
asimoglu and uh and robinson
and they begin with a story of the
colonization of the new world
and um
let's see how much detail do i want to
tell the story so when this when the
spaniards in the portuguese colonize
central and south america
they encountered very hierarchical
societies
societies that were already despotic you
might you might say
and so they could succeed just by
lopping off the head of
these hierarchical societies and
becoming the gruelers
they didn't have to bring any women they
didn't have to bring any farmers they
could just become the rulers of these
hierarchical societies
and um and the british when they
colonized north america they wanted to
do the same thing
and so the jamestown colony came without
any farmers without any women they were
going to conquer the indians and get
gold and
do the same thing well that wasn't going
to work for a whole
bunch of reasons and so the next thought
was to import british laborers and
recreate a feudal
society they were housed in barracks
they couldn't run away on pain of death
and and so that didn't work either
because actually they could run away and
there was nothing
to do about it and so then this little
colony
was forced by circumstances by adverse
circumstances so this was very
existentially insecure
they were forced to become more fair in
order to
survive only when they instituted rules
that gave a better deal
do everyone in the colony could it
survive
as a colony so there's a sense in which
democratic governance and equality and
so on actually
was necessary for survival
in harsh
environments what was this better deal
well um if you were to become part of it
you'd be given your own landform
example you wouldn't be a just a serve
working on the estate of a rich people
you were given your own plot of land and
so on you were given a voice in decision
making
i wanted to know what are the
preconditions for liberalism
i was thinking about this i was thinking
was it was you mentioned which was
existential security well no because you
just flipped that you said actually
liberalism can thrive and then produce
some security
even harsh environments and then i was
wondering well
are there memetic preconditions are
there memes
that need to be dispersed in the society
and
adopted before liberalism could come
about and if so what would those memes
be
do you have any ideas well other other
people can
do a better job recounting the
history of this but i'll do the best
that i can
for one thing
the cultural evolution of european
society can definitely be seen as a
process of multi-level
selection basically competition between
polities resulting in larger and larger
polities ultimately the scale of
european nations you go back far enough
and you find all these little
city-states hundreds and hundreds
of them why don't they exist anymore
it's because they had to amalgamate
in order to fight each other and so
that's what resulted in nations the size
of
uh of um european nations
that's when when it comes to nation
building and things like that and we go
to other parts of the world such as
africa
the middle east afghanistan which never
actually ever achieved that scale of
governance and then we expect them to
adopt a european
model that typically doesn't work
because they never achieved that
scale of uh that scale of governance so
what you ended
up with were very large societies that
ultimately became
autocratic and
once again ceased to work for the common
uh good and then democratic forms of
governance
emerged from their liberalism
the enlightenment values emerged from
there
and why and then
that then asserted greater equality
and uh ultimately resulted in more
powerful
nations if you look for example at the
at the competition between england and
france england is a quarter the size of
france but managed to punch above its
weight in part because
of such things as the industrial
revolution why did that take place in
england and not
france is because actually if you're an
inventor some kind of craftsman or
or watchmaker or something like that in
england and you came up with an
investment you had a way to develop that
investment in a way that you would share
the
benefits of it was it was enough
equality so that the merchant class for
example had had enough so that they
could actually
benefit from this sort of thing then in
a more aristocratic
uh society and you didn't have to have
many decades of that before you would
have technological advances and so on
and so forth in which you could punch
above your
of your uh your wage
so so and if you look at the actual
religion of these democratic
movements
the masons the freemasons become
a very interesting story here i don't
know if we want to go into it but
freemason societies started out
as actually societies of of uh
architects basically the people that
built the great cathedrals and
and so on so it was building and and
and architects but then it morphed into
a kind of a philosophical society
that could accommodate more sectors of
the
society than normal aristocratic society
so you could become a freemason
and mingle with people
that you couldn't do otherwise out of
your uh
station and then
and then they were the first ones to
form a actually written constitution
that's a long story i'm sure it but it's
um it's really quite fascinating that
once again in small groups this became
incubated
and then expanded and uh led to the
um to the democratic revolutions in
france and
and um america and all through all
through europe in some ways was a
scaling up
of a form of governance that originated
in um
in these little tiny societies i
remember in this view of life you were
talking about
how the europeans used to go and
study other cultures and rate them
essentially on a scale of civilized to
savage
and that was the wrong way of obviously
the wrong way of going about it
a better way was to be would be
something akin to looking at the inuit
and seeing how they're accustomed to the
cold and they have their own practices
to deal with it
and then we can say oh they're not
savage they're
adapted to that environment okay so then
my question was
they're adapted because they survive
well in that environment
then the europeans came along and
invented cities and
technology and now they can survive in
alaska and
the coldest parts of the world maybe
better but that's a question i want to
ask you is what does it mean to be
adapted
and if and if these white europeans
let's just call them white europeans
came and settled
and now made brick houses with fire and
electricity that
goes right through are they not more
adapted than
the inuit then because they're able to
survive better in these colder
environments
oh you there's a whole bunch of things
you raised there so let's try to unpack
them
one by one uh i'm lucky
to be trained as an evolutionary
biologist a lot of people that are
playing this game
were trained in some of the human
related disciplines and they picked up
their
evolutionary theory playing what game uh
well the whole thinking of all aspects
of humanity from an evolutionary
perspective basically this view of life
um extending evolutionary thinking to
explain all aspects of
of humanity that's the game that i'm
sorry you mean to say that you have the
advantage in that you were
in constant evolutionary thinking first
then started to apply it out where yeah
other people yeah and actually yeah and
i'm a bit unusual
uh that way the reason i mention it is
that
um sophisticated evolutionary thinking
includes basically showcases
adaptation but there's a lot of other
stuff
as well and so when we look at things
that are out there
sometimes they're adaptive sometimes
they're not even when they're adaptive
then what counts as adaptive in the
evolutionary sense of the word doesn't
necessarily correspond to in the
normative
sense of the word so back to the way we
should be looking at cultures
and during the victorian victorian era
it was
very difficult for darwin along with his
colleagues to not to think of european
culture as superior in some sense
to all other cultures yet a more true
evolutionary approach as you just said
would be that most cultures
are at least to some degree well adapted
to their
circumstances and so uh that's a more
respectful
way to approach cultures and one which
is truer to evolutionary
uh theories so in that sense the inuits
are better adapted to an arctic climate
than
than europeans at least at first now
you're saying
that
such modern conveniences is housing and
and heating and
so on is well adapted and of course
those have been
adopted by inuits they don't live in
igloos
but if they did let's imagine that there
are some that still do
well i mean that's not imaginary there's
all kinds of uh of uh
indigenous people that uh actually want
to want to stick to their indigenous
uh ways and
to to a greater or lesser degree and and
one point to make i think is that that
should be their choice
so uh and you see
very interesting regions such as ecuador
which have
still a large indigenous
and diverse you know many tribes in
ecuador that are now being represented
in
in in the government
and so it's like our choice what do we
want to do do we want to
modernize our or not often they might i
mean such things as
as medicine i mean who wants to do
without modern medicine not many
people so so
it's a it's a very complex situation but
one which needs to be handled
in a uh egalitarian
fashion that acquires respect to all of
the different uh
stakeholders there's a sense in which
and this is once again the egalitarian
impulse no matter who i am what culture
i represent
uh there's some sense in which i need to
be a moral equal
and that my existence counts
i have some kind of say in the
decision-making process based on
my values and so
that's the that's the concept of moral
um equality which i think is pretty much
uh culturally universal
not restricted to weird societies is
that uh
however the us gets defined then
um then there's some uh
feeling of of equality and that that has
a
a uh
an insistent dimension basically not
only am i a moral equal but i will
resist you
if you infringe upon infringe upon that
so if we're going to do something
together it has to be in some sense
why with my acquiescence
i have to i have to be able to say yes
to that
speaking on that you mentioned most of
the time when we're doing studies it's
on weird quote unquote people
and we can't necessarily generalize and
say that that's a human universal when
we talked about
moralistic behavior being virtuous and
courageous or virtue being
virtually encouraged virtue being
courage and honesty and forthrightness
and so on and so forth
is that a human universal
um close i think would be part of the
human repertoire
um i'm just wondering because
i don't know and i'm curious i don't
know if certain tribes or certain other
places in the world would say
well actually to be a moral person is to
cut the head off your enemy and put it
on your fence
well yeah that that that too i mean
as soon as you talk about how we behave
towards them
then um anything can go as we've already
as republicans said the world is full of
situations in which we
the group are threatened by them
and the moral thing for us to do is to
cut off their heads and put it on a
stake it could also be moral that line
could also be moral
what's that so i'm just going to cut
that line the moral thing for us to do
is
by taking stone wilson thank you very
much yeah that's it that's all that's
going online
thank you it can also be moral it could
also be moral to take the deviant within
the society and cut off their head and
put it on a
honest day these things are the only the
way we think these are immoral
uh get this little padding feet up here
it's okay just continue i don't know if
you know who janice fiomingo is
she's a professor of english when i was
interviewing her she her cat just came
right right upon her list you can sit up
here if you want
i don't think that's gonna that'll keep
you silent and i can take you leave
boom yeah
now your your viewership will go way up
if you include the dog in the picture
okay okay so where are we so these
things appear immoral to us because
we're taking a third person stance we're
we're not
we're not thinking of us as being in
that
that group and so therefore we're
looking at these between group
behaviors and also the the the policing
the policing behaviors which cause us to
be cruel to members of our own
group and we're seeing this in some kind
of third person vantage
which makes it appear immoral so much
depends upon the perspective
are you a moral relativist would you
consider yourself to be that
how would you define moral relativism
that
there are no objective moral standards
pretty much what every culture has is
good for them no i'm not
at all a moral relativist i think that
that morality
axiomatically is about the welfare of
others
and society as a whole as defined by the
by the community and there's nothing
arbitrary about what counts as moral or
immoral uh from the perspective of
members of the
moral uh well you said as defined as
by the community so if they define it
any way they want is that
okay are there some
limits boundaries
well typically one of my favorite
authors as a
novelist is joseph conrad who wrote
many books about the sea and he once
said that
he likes writing books about the sea
because they're so morally simple
very simply if you're on a ship then
what you need to do is to
stay afloat you know who the group is
and you know what they need to do they
need to stay afloat
and so that provides a clarity a moral
clarity
which does not exist in other situations
where we don't really know who the group
is and we don't really know what we need
to do to stay afloat
right that makes things complex
but if you take a ship then
that moral clarity i think argues
against relativism
at least on a ship there's nothing
relative about what counts as
moral or who's in or who's out or
or anything like that that's why space
fantasy is so
compelling for the same uh
for the same uh reason whenever we think
of ourselves as
in the same boat then
and and when we think about like
survival as being really
salient then things become morally clear
that's there's an important insight
let's let's let's let's acknowledge
progress where it exists to be able to
say that i think
is then helpful when we now consider
more
ambiguous situations
i wanted to know if you think that what
happens in the universities is
isolated from society or not isolated
and i'll explain what i mean
someone like stephen hicks a philosopher
says well
you shouldn't you should be people who
are a part of the general public should
be concerned about
the quote-unquote corruption of the
humanities by the
post-modernist now i'm not having you
take a stance on that but
he would say you should be concerned
even though it seems like it's
a relatively obscure isolated
part of the whole country it's just one
part of the university
you should be concerned because what
happens in the university spreads
outwards to the rest of society
and i wanted to know what are your
thoughts on that is it true that what
happens in the universities
spread out to the rest of society so we
better be careful as to
i certainly hope so i certainly hope so
are these intellectuals sorry i mean to
say even in fields that one might not
think
have anything to do with society so for
example
english well english probably does have
something to do with society given that
we speak it but
english linguistics
women's studies gender studies so i
think i think that
higher education universities and
colleges are a fascinating
study of cultural evolution in their own
right and
all things considered of course higher
colleges and universities would not
exist
and also the branches of academic
knowledge wouldn't exist
if they didn't have some impact on the
rest of life often that's quite indirect
i think it was
keynes the economist who said that even
someone who doesn't think that they're
influenced by economists actually are
they're being influenced by some defunct
economist
from long uh
from long ego so these ideas do matter
even though it seems that they might
not so there's one point to be uh
one point to be made we should care
about what they say but another point
that needs to be made is that is that
all of the branches of academia
um need to become much more unified
than they are
and so the fragmentation of knowledge i
think is a problem that needs to be
acknowledged and i actually have a
biological kind of metaphor
for for that back to my training as a
biologist
so if you actually look at a archipelago
which is a collection of islands you
find they're biologically
extremely diverse many species on
archipelagos why is that
well it's because of barriers to gene
flow
so if you're isolated on an island then
there's no gene flow with other
islands and so those populations tend to
drift apart before lying they become
different species
and they can't there couldn't any breed
even if they were
brought together also on single islands
there's species that occupy different
niches and so they become different for
that
for that reasons and so archipelagos are
very
diverse okay got that now
think of academia as an archipelago
in which with many islands of
of knowledge so basically you have all
of these different
groups schools of thought
that are developing their ideas largely
in isolation
from each other and this includes not
just the major disciplines but all the
schools of thought within any given
discipline they're not talking to each
other so what happens
well they begin to develop different
vocabularies use the same words in
different ways it goes this way it goes
there
pretty soon what you get is like a form
of cultural speciation
which is mutual and comprehension
no one can understand each other it's a
tower of babel you might
so so that's not a good thing so
that's that's the kind of diversity
that's not worth wanting diversity is
not good
per se there's forms of diversity that
are not worth
wanting and that's one of them so there
needs to have some sense in which
in which people can communicate with
each other
and that's not happening that's one
major goal evolutionary theory plays is
to
is to actually provide that unification
of knowledge
as it already has in the biological
sciences and can
for all things human okay i was just
about to ask so how
do you see it being unified but you said
it would probably start from
evolutionary sciences and this is a hard
point to make because it seems
um self-serving it seems uh
what's the word i want to use
proprietorial or or um
totalizing as is often put but there's
um
hold on a second what the heck is
totalizing totalizing yeah
what do you mean by that uh what's the
word of totalizing it's a postmodern
term it's
it's basically that you're kind of
imposing a world view on others
and privileging it okay so
and of course there's a trigger
sensitivity
to to that which we can appreciate but
that loses the fact that
um that um
that when you go back to
the way darwin approached different
people back then before evolution we had
naturalists they studied plants and
animals
all these different branches of
biological knowledge embryology
biogeography all the different
contrivances of plants and animals
natural natural history
and what darwin did was he actually
managed to put these
together a single theory that made sense
of all of these branches
of knowledge so and that didn't
eliminate them
it organized them so that's what can
take place now is taking place now
quite rapidly in historical terms um so
[Music]
so that's that's a great thing when do
you think the left goes too far
ideologically speaking
i think that anyone goes too far
when they uh let me just try to think
about this for
for uh
so
i think that anyone goes through fire
when they when they
deny the authority of empirical evidence
if they're not being science-based
uh trying to work out what's actually
out there the facts of the matter
and then proceeding on that basis then
they become unmoored from
from reality and then the second problem
is
is uh is tribalism and i think the left
is as prone to tribalism as the
as the orion these little academic
tribes that we've
talked about i think is when they become
just universes in their own
in their own right then that becomes
part of the problem
sometimes it becomes a problem with like
you know
fighting between tribes but even without
that
you get academic tribes that become so
ingrown that they're only fighting for
each other
and it's that point they become
irrelevant and nobody should care other
than
their own their own kind and they wink
out of existence
you know after a period of after a
period of time so there has to be some
sense of remaining connected there's
some kind of common
project so that when we communicate we
actually are trying to do something
uh important at a large scale
which involves communicating with other
uh
people other other perspectives and so
on
and then actually working towards those
those solutions
i was going to ask you about the meme
gene interaction
so when is it or what are examples of
memes that have lasted so long i guess
we can only talk about human society
what memes have lasted so long such that
they affect
our genes the direction of evolution
maybe sexual selection portion of time
talking about memes and let's begin with
the derivation of the term and the
person who claimed it
of course it was richard dawkins and it
was
part of his book the selfish gene and
and then meme was some kind of cultural
analog
to gene and so you can't really
understand memes the way dawkins
introduce the term
without thinking also about genes the
way
dawkins conceptualize that term which is
really kind of esoteric for dawkins
a gene was actually not a physical
entity
it was some kind of unit for information
he thought about genes in an extremely
atomistic
sense he gave genes agency
he called them selfish and when in fact
genes are part of a biological system
they always interact with other genes
and they always interact with the other
components of the
organism so there's a systemic approach
to evolution
which includes genes in a more systemic
way
than dawkins did and without giving them
such
agency as selfish entities in their own
right
and so given the fact that dawkins
concept
of a gene was actually quite problematic
and and biology has moved beyond it
then we should be suspicious from the
beginning about
his concept of meme which inherited
most of the same properties he thought
of memes as as very atomistic
kind of evolving on their own he didn't
think of
complexes of memes he actually had a
term for them he called them meme
complexes
but never much thought about them um
he emphasized mostly the possibility
that memes can become parasitic
sorry complexes of memes are just
collections of memes yeah they're like
like complexes of genes if there's a
genotype why can't there be a memo type
well memo type doesn't exist as a term
meme complexes does but hardly anything
is done
with it and so we're left with the idea
that there's little bits of information
little cultural units that are kind of
evolving in some
soup on their own um
and you know some examples are like the
phrase of a song you know the first
phrase of happy birthday to you is a
meme
that spreads and so on and and so forth
and so
and so um the field of cultural
evolution
as it's developed i mean there are lots
of people that became entranced by the
concept of memes
and tried to do something with it there
were journals there was the whole field
of mimetics and so on and
and do you know those have tended to
peter groud
while the field of cultural evolution as
a whole as virgin
and so how can we talk about cultural
evolution
in some sense without buying into the
concept of memes is
we still use the word meme as a kind of
a shorthand for
some trade since we don't know the
mechanistic basis really what we're
talking about is some trait at the
phenotypic level
so when we want to talk about it a trait
that's learned and culturally
transmitted we call it a meme
that's fine but don't associate it with
some of these other things that
that is part of the dawkins
terminology now um
in a video that you asked me to watch
when jordan peterson he talked about
jungian
archetypes and if you go back to
some of the early psychological thinkers
such as jung and freud
you have to appreciate how
uh
how primitive the evolutionary thinking
was at that time so although they were
big thinkers and they were trying to
apprehend something
uh fred's concept of the unconscious and
the id and
his basic concepts and jungian concepts
such as the archetype
i mean there were reaching for something
but
we really have to evaluate it
critically from a modern evolutionary
perspective
again there was a baby in the bathwater
but there was also
quite a lot of bath water and we it's up
to us to
sort it out i think there is an
intriguing correspondence with what
jung talked about his archetypes with
what evolutionary psychologists talk
about as modules
and that's i think a better match than
memes
so evolutionary psychologists properly
say that that our evolved psychology is
highly adapted to solve the problems of
survival and reproduction in ancestral
environments and
often they take the form of of modules
specialized circuits that
that are dedicated to solving this
problem or that
and so um and so we could imagine for
example
an us them psychology which is like
built into us that gets triggered under
appropriate
uh circuits of mating psychology all of
these sorts of
all of these sorts of um of things and
so
is there some kind of fit between the
modules of evolutionary psychologists
and
and uh and uh what what jung was
reaching for with archives yeah maybe
maybe that's worth that's worth
exploring
also one of the things that's happened
recently is that a lot of what's been
attributed to genetic evolution
is now needs to be attributed to
cultural evolution
which is and take language for example
if you look at what chomsky
people like noel chomsky noam chonsky
thought about language and also steve
pinker it was
like a product of genetic evolution
there's a module for language
that kind of that kind of thing the
language instinct is
steve pinker put it there's a universal
grammar that we need to
decipher all of which makes it sound as
if language was something that evolved
directly by
genetic evolution but now it seems uh
to an amazing degree that language
is much more of a cultural construction
that has arisen more than once in
different geographical regions by
cultural evolution and the grammars that
evolved by cultural evolution actually
need not be universal no need
for that there's so many different
cultural
experiments and that many aspects of
human psychology
which we would think because they're so
unconscious and intuitive and so on
we'd think that there would be a a
modulus
evolutionary a genetically evolved
module
maybe not um maybe they're cultural
gadgets that have been around for so
long that
they've uh they seem less
they seem like first nature actually
they're second nature so
a lot which has been attributed to
genetic evolution
might need to be attributed to cultural
evolution that's how deep cultural
evolution
goes and that's pretty darn interesting
you mentioned in your book this view of
life that there's
innovation oasises which are like
geographic regions where innovation
happens
yeah and that there's some principles
that guide the growth of such a
oasis and then you outline seven i don't
know if you came up with the seven or
someone else did
well that was uh based on the work of
victor huang
who is a uh a leader in entrepreneurship
and
uh and innovation the point that i was
trying to make there
is that has to do with adaptability
um so many cultures are well adapted to
their environments
but how how adaptable are they to change
how how are they capable of actually
changing and adapting to
new circumstances that requires some
features
of a culture that don't always
exist and so i provided
a couple of examples from the business
world of companies that are not just
well adapted
but actually are capable of adapting
to new circumstances one of which was
toyota which is famous
as an adaptable corporation
and in the case of huang's work he
points out that isn't it interesting
that
i mean innovation is the name of the
game every region of the world every
university
every city wants to be entrepreneurial
and to be able to change
for the better but there's huge
variation
as hwang points out in
their ability to do so and silicon
valley
is an example what is it what's the
magic
ingredient and in a nutshell
and this is so very interesting
he says that there's two vital
ingredients one is
the need to cooperate it has to be
really cooperative culture
and it also has to be really diverse
and those two things don't go together
typically we cooperate in our in groups
right and our in-groups are relatively
homogeneous so it's kind of a special
thing
to have a culture where you cooperate
with
diverse people and that is
what takes place happens to take place
in
certain regions of the of the uh
of the world what are some other
innovation oasises besides
silicon valley he points to israel and
of course right away you have to
qualify what we mean by being inclusive
and diverse because israel is the very
opposite
as far as its exclusion of palestinians
for example so what does he mean he
means very narrowly
that the compulsory draft in israel
takes people from all sectors of an of
israeli society
and throws them together okay and so now
they're cooperating in a military
context
and then when they leave the military
then they're able to cooperate in other
contexts so it it takes the
diversity that exists within israeli
society
and it causes that to be
[Music]
cooperative and in the case of silicon
valley
we have a culture which is
maybe a little bit surprisingly much
more
easy going than you might think that
if you're an entrepreneur you're not
guarded of your ideas you're not
actually
out just to make a pile of money often
you have some kind of vision
and you're quite generous in in
sharing it people you know will invest
money on a handshake
a lawyer that juan quote says that if
you're a really good businessman you
don't need a lawyer at all
because you have trusting relationships
and and then actually if somebody
um acts selfishly in a context like that
because it's
quite a closed community everyone knows
each other well soon enough it
gets out that so-and-so didn't
behave right and nobody wants to do
business with them and so there's a
a very informal level of policing which
is
which is good enough uh it doesn't
require legal
uh uh restrictions and then once again
that's diverse in a sense but it leaves
all sorts of people out of the system
as well it could be very clubby and and
so on
uh so when we talk about being diverse
we have to qualify it
quite heavily well i was thinking
selfishly one of my goals i have a
company called indie film teo which is
a non-profit and it helps filmmakers
with their arts
so that they can be profitable with it
one of my goals is to make
toronto possibly the silicon valley of
film
yeah okay and then i was thinking oh
that's so cool that this guy
david stone wilson evolutionary
biologist outlined for me great thank
you
seven principles that need to be
engendered in this society in order to
induce
such such a oasis of innovation
right and then i was thinking wait a
second seek fairness not advantage
was one of the principles if i'm not
mistaken and then i was thinking wait
but that
in my opinion i used to live in san fran
and i know a little bit of the business
world
i don't know if that characterizes
silicon valley because
there is a bit of and a bit is a bit of
an understatement
there's a bit of bullying and and
corporate bullying
that happens now let's go to
hollywood seek fairness not advantage
definitely not equality that hollywood
has nor
does it have does it have the second
trait which is open doors and listen
well there's um i was very cliquey
i wish that i could channel my friend
victor
to have this conversation and there's
one dynamic that goes on that might
explain some of this which is like super
interesting and
and it has to do with once a company
succeeds
and and then becomes proprietorial
so there's i've become fascinated with
the open source software
development and all of its analogs
the linux development and stuff like
that by the way this movie that you're
in is an open source movie
it's the first of its kind at this scale
all the footage is being released for
people to see
so the dynamic is is that is that the
real creativity comes with this open
source process it's there that you get
victories seven ingredients people are
operating in a really cooperative mode
so on and so forth and that's
tremendously creative
and then you get companies such as
microsoft or apple
or so on that become really successful
they try to capture it all
and they're able to do so and once they
capture it then all the creativity
drains
out of it and then you have the open
source part of it
kind of sometimes it's just squelched
okay
and that capture is permanent but
sometimes as with linux
it actually flourishes and become so
good
that it beats out the proprietarial
competition and so as soon as you get
corporate basically as soon as things
turn corporate
then they tend to deviate away from
these principles that victor
was talking about what do you define as
becoming corporate
becoming corporate is is that basically
you become an entity that becomes profit
maximizing
and more interested in your own profit
instead of vision driven or then vision
driven and so on and
and so forth and in a book i recently
read called
the master switch by timothy wu
i believe his name is these are
well-known books that i'm just kind of
channeling
he talks about this dynamic again and
again and again
stretching all the way back to the
telegraph the telephone
radio television cable television
all communication
innovations that began in this open
source
fashion with this wonderful diversity
and then became captured
in some sense that was a good thing
because like you don't want more than
one telephone system frankly
i mean there's some sense in which one
big system
makes a lot of sense but not if it
eliminates innovation and in so many of
these cases once you become a
monopoly you don't want the next thing
you definitely don't want the next thing
and then the final version of this was
was hollywood
basically now being captured by a few
giant studios
churning out superhero movies and
but where is the diversity i mean
actually it does exist it exists with
the indie films and with
netflix and so on and so forth but the
dynamic
of this open source-y kind of
process in which those seven principles
that
victor talks about are present is
competing in a sense with these
leviathans
which do not have those properties
and cease to be innovative so i think
victor is right
um but that said you can point to
aspects of hollywood or silicon valley
that um that
are counting against that and even given
hollywood as it is i think
if you were to look at the assembly of a
of whatever team gets assembled for
any particular uh movie
with all of those credits at the end of
the movie
i mean it is a symphony of cooperation
and if you're the first grip or the
cameraman or something like that how you
come together
uh for something i'll bet is based on
your reputation the spirit of generosity
so and so
somewhere within the system i think that
those ingredients that victor was
talking about
might be present but i don't know
so what do you say to people who claim
that there's no such thing as biological
sex
for example i sent i don't know if you
got a chance to look at the video there
was a professor who said
there is no such thing as biological sex
i'm a historian of medicine and i can
debunk that
but then he didn't go on to debunk it
well i think that that's not correct
that there is such a thing as biological
sense but where we draw the line
is
and where it's been drawn before by
scientists and doctors is
pretty shameful and has been revealed to
be false in
in retrospect i think that uh anne is in
my wife ann is in earshot but uh uh
she'll tell you that back in the 70s
when
she was a young woman it was received
scientific wisdom that women's bodies
would fall apart if they were to run a
marathon
how's that and so what is essentially
male and female
i think so often is socially constructed
for the benefit of
the powerful members of of um
of societies and so more often than not
we have to pay attention to
to the socially constructed um
aspects so but at the end of the day
we just have to let the chips follow
where they where they may
earlier i was talking about the inuit
and i think my question could be more
simply asked
it's a rudimentary question what is
adaptive defined as
is it simply your propensity to
reproduce is it that you're not
experiencing pain in your environment
what is the definition of adaptiveness
that's such that we can say this is more
adaptive than this well the narrow
definition of adaptedness is something
which
uh survives and we produce better than
its alternatives
right and so that's true for genes
uh drift is not adaptation if we have a
case of genetic drift where they have
two things that
have the same survival and reproduction
well chance is going to cause one to
become more frequent than the other but
that doesn't count as an adaptation
so it's not the case that anything that
evolves is adaptive
nevertheless if something becomes more
common based on its properties
then it counts as adaptive in the
evolutionary
sense of the word and so
that's the definition that is standard
in
for genetic evolution and to a
pretty large degree it also counts not
just for cultural evolution but also
um learning if you look at the
schenerian process of
of operant conditioning and you you put
the
the uh rat in the maze and it
does a bunch of stuff and presses the
lever and gets some food and
ends up pressing the lever because that
was the behavior that
that delivered rewards more than other
behaviors what's called the matching
laws basically a comparison of
alternative behaviors
and it's saying the one that's most
rewarding it gets amped up
so it's adaptive do you believe in free
will
yeah i do i think that on that i side
with the early daniel bennett
daniel dennett and i don't agree on many
things but
he wrote a book called elbow room
varieties of free will worth wanting
that basically uh equates free will with
the latitude
to make choices and so i think that's a
a common sense definition of free will
that
both exists and worth wanting but to
elaborate on that just a bit
uh you told me earlier about your
physics background and the theory of
everything which is
basically very reductionistic
concept that knowing only about the
physical world we might be able to
explain
everything and i think that there's
something
profoundly false about that and
which is revealed by evolution and that
evolution
is not at all deterministic there's
something
not probabilistic but uh basically
evolution
um results in in
things which uh
they exist by virtue of of their
adaptedness
and and you can't predict them on the
basis of their physical
properties there's this concept of
downward causation
that when something evolves on the basis
of
of survival and reproduction
the parts permitted it to happen but
they didn't cause it to happen as long
as the physical material results in
heritable variation
then it's the environmental forces which
cause something to be
brought into being and so
the theory of everything has to include
evolutionary
theory and there's a large portion of
evolutionary theory which is amazingly
detached from
physical processes at all
i mean everything that evolves has a
physical process but that physical
process did not determine
what he wanted all it provided was the
raw material of
heritable variation and so
all of that i think is really provides a
lot of christopher
for thinking about uh free will
okay now my last question this is just
one that i've
been thinking about my last questions
are killers i want to say my last
question is
i'm a scientist so i i'm a scientist
at heart but i always like to critique
and critique critique so i was thinking
i was thinking i have this document of
theories that i feel like undermine
themselves and post-modernism is one of
them because it says there are no truths
and therefore any
claims to truth is power
self-contradictory but yeah exactly
because that's
a truth that you've claimed the power
truth the proud power narrative in other
words
okay then i was thinking about evolution
the evolution is interesting because
in a sense it can undermine itself and
i'll explain how
we're selected not for our interaction
with
reality as such or the objective world
but we're selected
for what allows us to reproduce and that
may not necessarily match up to reality
so another philosopher and i don't
remember his name said that even
this world that we think is solid is we
should think of it more like
a computer icon that says that looks
like
a mail and then we don't confuse that
mail icon with the mail itself that's a
user interface
so all of this is a user interface
because that's all the evolution
provides you is
the ability to interact with the world
such that you get what you want and
hopefully that's something like survival
okay so then that means that we don't
we're not selected necessarily
for our relationship with reality
which means that whatever we think of as
real might not necessarily be real
including the theory of evolution so if
the theory of evolution is true
which obviously like i i believe you
believe i would
then we can use it to undermine itself
by saying the theory of evolution would
say that we don't
we're not selected to match with reality
including
our own theory of evolution and i want
to know what you think of that because
this is just something i thought about
for five minutes well that line of
reasoning would undermine
any theory so uh but i think the the
best part of what you just said
is that you're right what we
perceive as reality has is based on its
survival value
not on a direct apprehension of of
reality
fortunately
i would qualify that a bit to say that
that
the relationship between objective
reality and survival value
is sometimes positive and sometimes
negative
sometimes knowing the world as it really
is
helps us survive in that world and
sometimes
flagrant departures from reality helps
us survive
in the world what that means is that
we're able to function in both modes
that we actually have a module you might
say
we have ways of thinking that that are
proto-scientific
and that's proto-religious
uh let's put it to bitter cooler so that
we do have a capacity to function as
in scientific objective reasoning
modes to to decide upon
what's out there and then science is an
elaboration of that but the
the point to make is that is that even
if we didn't evolve to
apprehend reality luckily we have a
procedure which we call the scientific
method
which actually is capable of
doing that it doesn't come too naturally
for us
and it has to be a social process it's
not an individual process
but are we lucky that there's a social
process that enables us to actually
determine
what's out there
and that's why we need to we need to
protect science and make it the
centerpiece of what we do
in a modern world because more and more
our survival does depend on knowing
the world as it really is so we need
science more than we ever did before
thank you man
i think there's a pattern with this and
you're familiar with daniel bennett's
second endosymbiotic revolution right
where we get memes
yeah right so what struck me
in when i was i studied both my major in
history and biology
minored in philosophy and what struck me
was so many similarities between
these disciplines one of which was
in biops just starting with
prokaryotes you have these vessels
that have a coat and that coat
you know is the inflates or helps the
interface between themselves and the
environment
navigates them through life the ones
that make it
continue ones that die die
right then miracle occurs and this is
going really well and then a miracle
occurs
first endosymbiotic revolution they're
trapped together as one
and in being trapped they externalize
their internal codes into a new system
still within the boundary of the the new
wall which is called that
the new wall and this new externalized
code
becomes the interface or let's say
tailors the interface of the new wall
and runs you know what is kind of the
face of their evolution
to be i know i'm being a bit yeah you
know
the next question i had was
okay does the pattern contain do they
gather together
a bunch of eukaryotic cells do they
gather together externalize their code
and that code changes the interface of
that new wall
and thus governs their evolution in that
hierarchy and of course this is daniel
then it's memes
right uh i mean daniel dada i don't want
to disparage him but but
i mean this has a whole literature that
doesn't depend on daniel dennett
absolutely major transitions of
evolution maynard smith
so anyhow i'm not sure i haven't read
dan's take on it but uh
but whatever i mean listen we say memes
right just to bring it down
do memes gather together
externalize their code
and then have that code govern some
larger interface
which governs their evolution my
question to you is
is that what history is that we come up
with the law
or written text and this externalized
text
governs our evolutions and thus
the evolution of our of our first our
ideas
then of our gen our dna then of our rna
and does that code then take on new life
and become for example computer code
which
acting upon itself ever trying this is
the new push getting it to evolve upon
itself
is this going to be the next level of
consciousness
the next code that is externalized from
us that
governs our lives our evolution and that
computers in this way your code is alive
follows this
matryoshka russian nesting gold trend
well that's my set of questions okay
well i mean
broadly uh yes to that last one believe
it or not
and uh i think quite a lot about that
and uh so i think that you're
traveling in a good direction one of my
projects
uh with uh
funded by one of the templeton
foundations is to actually
create to first do interviews and then
to
create a documentary series on
major transitions from the origins of
life to the internet age
so it's really that story that you were
saying that we're
documenting by interviewing experts
and i'm working with a documentary
filmmaker named ellen honik
who has really immersed himself in this
and so he's achieved
expert's level of knowledge with a lot
of creative input
on his own and we're interviewing people
like
a spot murray athena octopus who studies
cancer from an
evolutionary perspective rich michoud
who's contributed to this all the way up
to
internet folks like tim o'reilly and and
and and the like as to how
there's uh we're at the point now where
we need to have a the final transition
up to a global
consciousness if you've read my book
this year of life you know that i
accurate with pierre gel de chardin his
concept of the amiga point
um and and so on so it sounds like
science fiction
um and these transitions are very much
transitions of information
as you say so um
and it ends up with a symbiosis that's
going to be thoroughly entwined with
technology
and so on i mean the internet will be
the global nervous system but
it does not self-organize there's one
point that needs to be made
it's not happening no it cannot it has
to be guided by a selection process
and it's here that we have to be
targeting the global good
uh making that the target of selection
and if we don't do that then it won't
happen for sure
so this is where the idea of managing
cultural evolution what does that mean
it means managing all three components
of an evolutionary process those three
components are
selection variation and replication
what does it mean to manage them it
means we have to
decide the target of selection the
global good
orient variation around the target
and then replicate best practices
that's what needs to be done all with
the global good uh
in mind and nothing less will do so it's
uh
pretty amazing that you could actually
make a strong statement like that and
yeah i thought about it in my undergrad
um i discovered dennett i don't know if
you'll believe me
afterwards and when i found about your
powdered light revolution institute
i was very very excited
to speak well that's that's awesome and
i hope that you can get involved
and so we'll uh well what i'm
one of the things i'm trying to do is
actually uh
literally build a movement which is uh
you're building an army
and i i love it well not yet influx not
yet but
uh but hopefully and has the same kind
of
energy as a political movement but with
uh
uh motivated by an evolutionary
worldview rather than a political
ideology
that's the goal so any health would be
appreciated